[Müzik]
insan
oğlunu ayrı kılan özelliği
bilmesi öğrenebilmesi
dir insanlar olarak bizi bu Yetimin
Üstün kıldığına inan
ıyorum bu başka canlılarda
Tam da bu sırada bizim amacımızda
yönelik yapay zekaya
başlıyor Yapay Zeka diye bahsettiğimiz
kavramın tarihi İkinci Dünya Savaşı'na
dayanıyor
bu tarihi hemen hemen modern
bilgisayarların çıkması ile aynı
tarif yapay zekanın babası olarak
bilinen adın turney yapay Zekai ilk
olarak bol
bir makine Londra
makine Almanların Enigma aksanı denilen
şif
re renk başarılarından dolayı Savaş
kahramanı bile sayılıyor
savaştan sonra
dergisinde yayınlanan makalesinin ilk
cümlesine şöyle başlıyor Kendi eşiniz
değil yani makinalar düşünebiliriz ve
Aslında bu soruyla geleceğin temelini
yapay zekayı Cem saydam öğrendiğin üzere
üç başlıkta inceleyebiliriz
ilk olarak anlatarak öğren
me anlatarak öğrenme dediğimiz kavramı
Aslında bizim yapay zeka ile tanışmamızı
sağlayan
1997 yılında meydana gelen satranç
turnuvasında
geomu da bu sisteme
programcıları
vardı Daha sonra detaylı bir şekilde
Blue
aktarıyorlar daha sonra
prova'yı da problem için sonsuz adet
bilgi öğrenmenin etkili olmayacağını
fark etti ve yapay zekanın bizi korkutan
taraf
ına geçti kendi kendine öğrendi
yine oyunlardan gidecek olursak
Rönesans al
fa Gold yani Alfa Gold'un programcıları
önce birkaç kova örneğini Alfa boyayı
yüklüyorlar daha sonra alfabe bunları
inceleyip kendi kendine sonuçlar elde
edip kendi tecrübesini yaratarak insan
zihninin üzerinde bir noktaya veriyor
üçüncü olarak görerek
öğrenmek görerek öğrenme dediğimiz
kavram Biz insanlar için çok basit
Bizler bir fotoğrafa baktığımızda
kişilerin kim olduğunu kolayca ayırt
edebiliriz fakat Yapay Zeka için bu iş O
Kadar Kolay olmaz
yapay zekanın bir kişiye algılamasını
sağlamak için
binlerce renk dizisini yüklenmesi daha
sonra algılamasını istediğiniz bireyin
renkli egmentleri tanımlanmasını ona
verdiğimiz örneklerdeki tahminlerini
Evet ya da hayır şeklinde onaylamamız
gerekir ve bu sayede Yapay Zeka
[Müzik]
Yapay Zeka günümüzde bize film zevkinize
uygun bir film öner
mede trafikte navigasyon sistemleri
aracılığıyla yardımcı olm
Ada dilini bilmediğ
imiz bir acı olmada ve de
bize uygun bir grup Öner
mede pek çok alanda fayda sağlar
Fakat artık günümüzde Yapay Zeka yapımı
basit örneklerinden farklı olarak pek
çok alanda daha
örnek olarak 3 farklı alalım bakalım
birincisi bankacılık internet
bankacılığı
başta gelişmiş
ülke artık günümüz insanı bankacılık
işlemlerinin mobil uygulamalarından
sağlıyor
bizler her geçen gün televizyonda
[Müzik]
bir faydalanabilecek
imize de ve artık Bizler bankacılık
işlemlerimizi bankaya gitmek yerine
telefonlarımızı hallediyoruz
ikinci olarak pazarlama
pazarlamayı yapay zekayla pek çok yerde
pek çok farklı şekilde kullanabiliriz
Bugün size bizim de çoğu zaman fark
ettiği
kişiselleştirilmiş reklamlar sayesinde
bireylerin ilgisi canlı tutul
uyor sayede firmalar
reklamları ilginç duymasını sağlıyor
Hatta geçenlerde bu alanda çok büyük
bir reklam ajansı
üzerine bir kamera
konuma bu kamera
kişilerin yüz ifadesini algılayabilecek
miyiz Yani postere bakıldığında
ilk Posteri değiştirip uygun Reklamların
ideal kitleye Ulaş
masını bir diğer alanımız
her biri için kendini Özgür
dür eğitimde öğretmenler aracılığıyla bu
yolcu da Öncül
fakat en tecrübeli öğretmenler bile aynı
anda pek çok kişiye yet
emez yapay zekayı öğretmenlere yardımcı
olmak amacıyla kullanabiliriz Bu sayede
öğrencilerimizin eksiklerini daha erken
kişiye özgü metodlarla giderebiliriz
Ayrıca yapay zekayı öğrencilerin
bilgilerini daha iyi analize edip
bilgileri doğrultusunda meslek seçmeleri
için de kullan
abiliriz Yapay Zeka pek çok alanda
ilerliyor bizim yerimizde pek çok işçi
yapıyor
ve bize pek çok konuda geride bırak
ıyor Tabi şimdi bir Terminatör örneği
verip kimseyi korkutmak istemiyorum ama
birkaç
ürkütücü yapay zekâ
ilk olarak Yapay Zeka deyince çoğu
insanın ilk aklına gelen sofiden
bahsetti
insansı bir Bedene
sahip Sofi diğer lisanslı robot
lar her katıp
Hatta geçtiğimiz yıllarda bu Tonight
Ben kazandım bu insanlığı yok etmek için
güzel bir başlangıç olacak dedi
o anda ne ün sunucu ne de seyirciler
budur Bunun farkına vardım
Böyle Bir tehlike karşısında bizim
sohbeti yok etmemiz bile zor Çünkü
kendisi Suudi Arabistan vatandaşı ve bu
durum ona Bizler gibi bir takım haklar
doğuruyor
şimdi daha az korkutucu Biz Beta
nispeten daha az korkutucu insan sperine
sahip olmayan bir örneğe bakalım
2016 yılında Microsoft bir chestos
modeli açtı
ve o Twitter hesabı açıldı Microsoft
modeli için
insanlığa şöyle seslendim ta ile konuşun
Sayın Öğretmeniniz siz olun telsizinle
konuştukça kendini geliştirecektir dedi
çek Bulut açıldıktan sonra baştaki o
insanlığı seviyorum Merhaba dünya dilini
bırakıp cinsel içerikli yorumlar yapan
ırkçı küfürbaz bir hal aldım hal almaya
bunun üzerine Microsoft'un programcıları
tek hesabını kapatıp bir takım
düzenlemeler
yaptım Sayın şuan söylemlerini
gerçekleştirebilecek gücü yok fakat
düşünceleri de yok değil Şu anda kontrol
bizim elimizde fakat İleride böyle
olacağına dair bir Kesinlikle yok
üstüne üstlük bu Fenomen örnekler
başta dediğim gibi Yapay Zeka pek çok
alanda kullanılabilir
ama geliştir
savaş teknolojisi de bu alanlardan biri
olmaya
müsait savaş teknolojisi ve yapay zekaya
bir örnek verecek olursak intihar
modülleri
bunun için insan modülü dediğimiz
sistemler Araş edebilme yetkisine sahip
ve bu yetkiyi
kullanarak Yani bir hedef
in senin olmadığında
Yapay Zeka teknolojisi gelişiyor bizi
pek çok alanda geride bırakıyor
ve bizim bizim aklımıza bizi kurcalayan
aklımızı kurcalayan bir takım sorular
bırakıyor Yapay Zeka insanlığı yok
edecek mi
güçsından çıkacak yoksa mesleklerimizi
elimizden mi alacak bizim aklımıza
kurcalayan bu sorularla Yapay Zeka
teknolojisi gelişiyor ve bu gelişm
elere bazı bir hissel faaliyetleri
kısmında ortaya atılmaya başlandı
4 endüstriyel devrinde robotların
birbirleriyle konuşabilmesi
birbirlerinden öğrenebilmesi amaçlanıyor
Bu sayede insanlar
ve robotları çalıştığı mekanizmalar
hedefleniyor hedeflenen bu mekanizmalar
sayesinde Biz insanlar olarak pek çok
kavramı öğrenmek zorunda olduğumuz pek
çok kavramın peşinden koşmak zorunda
bulun
dum dünyaya değiştirebileceğiz
hedeflenen bu mekanizmalar sayesinde
teknoloji gelişiyor ve gelişmeye devam
edecek
araştırmanız sayesinde araştırmam
boyunca herhangi kesin bir bilgiye
Varamadım girecek hakkında kesin bir
bilgim yok fakat farkına vardığım şey
teknoloji gelişiyor Biz de bu teknolojik
gelişmelerin gelişmesini seyirci kalmak
yerine teknoloji ile birlikte gelişmeli
ve bazı teknolojik devirimlerin öncüsü
olmal ıyız sözlerimi maksiminin
sözleriyle noktalamak isterim
Rüzgarın yönünü değiştiremiyorsanız
yelkenlerinizi değiştirin teşekkürler
[Alkış]